معارك السودان تدخل اسبوعها ثالث رغم
الهدنه المعلنه غارات جويه وقصف مدفعي
واطلاق نار في الخرطومه تجدد الاشتباكات
في محيط القصر الرئاسي ومواجهات في ام
درمان وللمره الاولى منذ اندلاع
الاشتباكات انتشار القوات الشرطه في
الخرطوم الجيش يقول انها فتحت مناطقها
بالعاصمه والدعم السريع يطالبها بالانسحاب
[موسيقى]
طرف الازمه وسجالنا على وقع المعارك
البرهان يؤكد التزام القوات المسلحه
بعمليه سياسيه تقود لقيام سلطه مدنيه
الجيش السوداني يؤكد احباط ما وصفها
بمحاوله فاشله للاستيلاء على الحكم بغطاء
سياسي قوات الدعم السريع ترفض الحوار مع
من اسمتها بالمجموعه التي تسيطر على قرار
القوات المسلحه
مبعوث الامم المتحده الى السودان يقول ان
طرفي الصراع بات اكثر انفتاحا على
المحادثات الاتحاد الافريقي يجري اتصالات
مع اطراف دوليه لوضع خريطه طريق لانهاء
الازمه ووزير خارجيه جنوب السودان يقول
للجزيره انه لم يتم وضعه جدول زمني للقاء
بين البرهان واحمتي ويحذروا من تدوين
الصراع
غداه اعلانك يافا ان التحضير لهجوم مضاد
واسع النطاق اشرف على نهايته هجوم بطائرات
مسيره يستهدف مستودعا للنفط في ميناء
الواقع تحت السيطره الروسيه في شبه جزيره
القرم بعد اقل من 24 ساعه على ضربات
صاروخيه روسيه على مدن في اوكرانيا اسفرت
عن مقتل العشرات
رغم الهدنه المعلنه والجهود الدوليه لوقف
القتال تدخل المعارك بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع الاسبوع الثالث تتواصل
عمليات الاجلاء وتتصاعد التحذيرات من
التداعيات الانسانيه للاشتباكات نستطلع
صوره مجمل المشهد السوداني وتطوراته في
هذا اليوم الخامس عشر من المواجهات في
تقرير للزميل عبد القادر عراضه
كان شمال الخرطوم بحري المدينه الثانيه
للخرطوم الكبرى مسرحا لمواجهه بالاسلحه
الثقيله والخفيفه بين الجيش السوداني وقوه
الدعم السريع متى السبب في انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي تخللها قصف جوي من الجيش
السوداني لاهداف لدعم السريع ورد من هذا
الاخير بمضادات الطيران في تفاصيل
التطورات وقعت الاشتراكات في شارع المعونه
وحي كارفور والشوارع الداخليه بالحلفايه
وتحديدا عند مدخل كبري الحلفايه شماليه
الخرطوم بحري حيث انتشر الجيش السوداني في
محيط الجسر وغير بعيد ايضا غربا في ام
درمان دارت اشتباكات بريخ الجنوبي للمدينه
واشار بيان للدعم السريع الى مهاجمه الجيش
السوداني معسكر لقوته بمنطقه الصالحه وقال
انه استولى على عتاد ومركبات واسقط طائره
من نوع ميغ للجيش السوداني حسب البيان
جنوبي الخرطوم والتحديدا في منطقه جبل
اولياء تحدث الجيش السوداني عن تصديه
لهجوم لقوات الدعم السريع على قاعده
النجوم الجويه وت عدد كبير من عربه الدفع
الرباعي لهذه القوات القاعده انشات عام 76
ونقلت الى قاعده الخرطوم عام 91 وبسبب
ارتفاع عدد الطائره العموديه وطائره النقل
نقلت مره اخرى لمنطقه جبل اولياء عام 2011
هذا المشهد السوداني في يومه الخامس عشر
لا تغيب عنه مواجهات متقطعه بالاسلحه
الثقيله وسط الخرطوم وتحديدا في مناطق
قريبه من قياده الجيش وقرب القصر الرئاسي
ومع انتشار الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع في احياء عديده شماليه وجنوبيه
الخرطوم سجدت عوده جزئيه لحركه المواصلات
العامه في المناطق الجنوبيه الشرقيه
للخرطوم بينما تحدثت وزاره الصحه
السودانيه عن تاثر اثنتي عشره ولايه
بالاشتباكات في ظل استمرار وضع انساني صعب
وتواصل عمليه الاجلاء لرعايه دول عديده
[موسيقى]
انضموا الينا من ام درمان مراسل جزيره حسن
رزاق ومن جنوبي الخرطوم مراسل جزيره محمد
الطيب محمد ابدا معك ابرز ما سجل من
خروقات هذا اليوم
اذا تحدثنا عن الاشتباكات التي وقعت خلال
هذا اليوم فانها وقعت في بالتحديد في
منطقه الخرطوم بحري في مناطق عده في شارع
المعونه وفي كوبري الحلفايه جسر الحلفايه
وفي منطقه الحلفايه هذه المناطق شاهدت
اشتباكاتنا بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع تقللها
ايضا قصف هذه المناطق خلال نحو قبل تقريبا
خمس ساعات من الان كنا سمعنا انفجار في
وسط الخرطوم لا نعلم بالواقع مصدره ومكانه
لكن كان انفجارا كبيرا في ذلك سمعناه نحن
هنا من منطقه جنوب الخرطوم المناطق التي
نقع فيها الان
ومتواجدين فيها نحن الان المناطق الجنوبيه
الشرقيه شهدت في الواقع هدوءا نسبيا جعل
المواطنين يتحركون خلال هذا اليوم لاول
مره رصدنا ح المواصلات العامه في هذه
المنطقه التي كانت غائبه خلال الاسبوعين
الماضيين منذ بديل الاشتباكات لم تكن هناك
حركه للمواصلات العامه ولاول مره شاهدنا
عدد من الحافلات وعدد من البساط الصغيره
ما يعرف بالتوكتوك الركشه هنا الذين كانت
هناك حركات ذؤوبه بما يعني ان ازمه
البنزين ومنقطاع الوقود قد انفرجت قليلا
او انه متاح في المناطق الهاديه والبعيده
عن تخوم العمليات العسكريه مثل منطقه
الازهري ومناطق الجنوبيه الغربيه في منطقه
الكلاكله وام درمان هذه المناطق نوعا ما
تشهد هدوءا وبعيده عن تخوم العمليات
العسكريه التي تقع هنا في وسط وجنوب شرق
الخرطوم وبالتالي هذا يعني ان هناك انسياب
في الامداد
الغذائي لاحظنا ان عدد من المتاجر هنا في
الجنوب الشرق
العاصمه المثلثه انفتاح لهذه المتاجر
الصغيره التي كانت تكون على الطرقات
شاهدنا باعه متجولون يخرجون
ويقدمون ما لديهم من بضاعه هذا يعني ايضا
ان السيول النقديه التي كانت لدى
المواطنين قد انعدمت وبالتالي الذين
يتقاضون اجر اليوم باليوم هم مضطرون الى
الخروج والعمل وقد يعني ايضا ان هناك
تعايشا مع هذا الواقع
يسعى عدد من المناطق التي هي بالقرب من
تخوم العمليات العسكريه
بالتعايش مع هذا الواقع والحركه بقدر
المستطاع هذه المنطقه عموما خلال اليومين
الماضيين لم تشهد اشتباكات مباشره وانما
كانت كنا نسمع الطلقات
المضادات للطيارات من حين الى اخر ولكنها
كانت هادئه نسبيا مما جعل الحركه نوعا ما
تعود تدريجيا لهذه المناطق فدا شكرا لك
محمد الطيب كنت معنا من جنوبيه الخرطومه
انتقل اليك حسن حسن مواجهات ايضا في امه
دورمان سجلت اليوم طبيعه هذه المواجهات
واين تركزت
طبيعه الاشتباكات فيها هي طبيعه مختلفه عن
الخرطوم هي طبيعه يمكن ان نسميها طبيعه
جويه ارضيه تاتي طائرات لسلاح الجو
السوداني تحاول ان تقصف مواقعها للدعم
السريع الذي يرد بالمضادات الارضيه
والقذائف والذخائر لكن اليوم وقبل اكثر من
ساعه كانت هناك اشتباكات او ارض سمعنا
اصوات اعير ناريه وطلقات كثيفه جدا في هذه
المناطق غربه وجنوب ام درمان يبدو ان
اشتباكا على الارض حدث بين الجيش السوداني
والقوات الدعم السريع وهي كانت تحدث بين
الحين والاخر قبل اسبوع ايضا كان هناك
اشتباك على الارض اليوم تكرره هذا
الاشتباك طبعا يعني هذا الطبيعه مختلفه
لكن تظل الاشتباكات في غرب وجنوب ام درمان
في نطاق جغرافي محدد وايضا في اوقات ليست
داعمه لكن
الطبيعه الجويه كما اسمينا هي مستمره على
مدار الاسابيع الماضيه اليوم كان هناك قصف
كثيف من صباح الباكر استيقظنا على اصوات
ذوي
لطائرات تحلق وايضا مضادات طائر مضادات
ارضيه خفت قليلا ثم تكررت لكن حتى هذه
اللحظه الاصوات الاشتباكات الارضيه نسمع
بين الحين والاخر الطلقات ناريه على اي
حال هذه المواجهات الاستمرارها يفاقم من
تداعيات السكان طبعا انا اتحدث المناطق
المعيفه هي مدينه كبيره جدا ولا يمكن
التعميم على على هذا الامر الحالات تتزايد
وتتناقص حسب ما انطلقنا الى شمال شمال ام
درمان هي منطقه هادئه نسبيا والحركه فيها
طبيعيه او شبه الطبيعيه لكن كل ما اقتربنا
من الجنوب والغرب وكل مرق اقتربنا من
الخرطوم او الجسور التي تنقل سكان من ام
درمان الى الخرطوم عبر النيل الابيض او
النيل الازرق هنا يبدو ان الاشتباكات زايد
المعاناه الانسانيه هناك رصدنا عده معاناه
انسانيه صحيه حدثونا بعض السكان ان النساء
التي هم على وشك الولاده والذين يحتاجون
الى زيارات منتظمه للاطباء والمستشفيات
يعانون باعتبار ان الحركه الى المستفات
بعدت حركه صعبه مع شحال البنزين وايضا
الناس تتخوف من الحركه بسبب السيوله
الامنيه وانعدام مظاهر الشرطه والرجال
الامن لكن حتى ان وصلوا الى المستشفى هناك
يعانون ايضا من نقص الامدادات الطبيه لكن
ايضا اكرر ان هذه الحاله لا يمكن تعميم
دولار ايضا رصدنا معاناه اقتصاديه الذين
يعملون بالاجراء اليوميه والذين فقدوا
مصدر دخل باعتبار ان الناس الان
يعني الرفاهيه الشخصيه يحتاج ان عامل
لمنزله او سباك او او كهربائي الان هم في
في في معاناه وفي تناقص في داخل اليوم
باعتبار الناس لديهم اوليات اخرى ايضا
بعض المحال داخل الاحياء بدات تفتح
ابوابها بشكل حذر لكن هناك حركه بسيطه
حركه طبيعيه بدات بدات تدق في بعض الاحياء
الداخليه كلما ابتعدنا من مناطق الاشتباك
لكن تظل التداعيات الانسانيه قاسم مشترك
للجميع شكرا لك حسن الرزاق مراسل الجزيره
من ام درمان
وفي تطور لافتا منذ اندلاع الاشتباكات قبل
اسبوعين اعلنت وزاره الداخليه السودانيه
نشر قوات الشرطه في الطرقات لتامين
الممتلكات العامه والخاصه وضبط الانفلات
وبثى ناشطون وصفحات محليه سودانيه مشاهد
تظهر انتشار قوات الاحتياط المركزي
التابعه للشرطه السودانيه في منطقه
الكلاكله بالخرطومه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قال الجيش السوداني ان وحدات من شرطه
الاحتياط المركزي بدات فتح مناطق جنوب
العاصمه الخرطومه واضاف الجيش السوداني
وان من وصفهم بالمتمردين استمروا في القصف
العشوائي لمناطق في محيط القياده ووسط
الخرطوم وام درمان وانهم مستمرون في
محاولات دفع قوات من غرب البلاد واوضح
الجيش السوداني ان قوته اشتبكت مع من
وصفهم بالمتمردين في مناطق الحلفايه وجنوب
ام درمان وان عمليات التنشيط حققت نجاحا
في المنطقه كما اوضح ان لجنه امن ولايه
غرب دارفور نجحت في الحد من التوتر القبلي
بين بعض المكونات الاجتماعيه بالولايه
في المقابل اللي حضرت قوات الدعم السريعه
بشده جامعه قيادات قوات الشرطه من
الانخراط في المعارك الدائره الان
وطالبتها بسحب جميع منتسبيها من المشاركه
مع الانقلابيين وبحسب وصف البيان واضاف
بيان قوات الدعم السريع ان الشرطه جهاز
مدني قومي يجب ان لا ينحاز لاي طرف دون
الاخر وحذر بيان قوات الدعم السريع الشرطه
وقياداتها بعدم التدخل حتى لا تضطر الى
التعامل معها كعدو بحسب وصف بيان قوات
الدعم السريع
قال القائد العام للجيش السوداني الفريق
عبد الفتاح البرهان ان القوات المسلحه لن
تكون رافعه لاي كيان او حزب او جماعه
للانقضاض على السلطه واكد البرهان التزام
الجيش بالعمليه السياسيه التي تقود الى
قيام حكومه مدنيه
قال الجيش السوداني انما ان ما احبط او
احبط خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين كان محاوله
فاشله للاستيلاء على الحكم بقوه المتمردين
وبغطاء سياسي اضاف الجيش في بيان ان
التامر كان كبيرا وخططت له جهات في الداخل
والخارج واكد الجيش ان قوته تعمل طبقا لما
هو مخطط لها وتؤدي مهامها بثبات وثقه
مشيرا الى انه يعمل على تهيئه الظروف
المناسبه لتتمكن الشرطه وباقي اجهزه
الدوله من استئناف عملها
في المقابل قالت قوات الدعم السريعه انها
ترفض الحوار مع المجموعه التي تسيطر على
قرار القوات المسلحه واضافت هذه القوات ان
الخلق المستمره لمن وصفته بالقيادات
الانقلابيه وفولو للنظام البائد المتطرفه
يعود السبب الى تنازع مراكز القرار وشددت
قوه الدعم السريع التزامها بالهدنه
الانسانيه لفتح ممرات امنه للمواطنين
وتسهيل اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب
انضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي السودانيه عادل الباز سيد
عادل اهلا بك المواجهات في الخرطوم تدخل
اسبوعها او في السودان تدخل اسبوعها
الثالث الى اين يتجه المشهد في السودان
المشهد يتجه الى ما بدا به وهو ان
كل الاطراف كانت مسره على حسم هذه المعركه
العسكريا والان ما يجري على الارض يشير
الى ان كل الدعوات المتعلقه بالتفاوض او
متعلقه بالهدنه لم تنجح ولا احد يرغب في
هدنه او تفاوض في هذا الوقت الحالي ولذلك
من عدم الحسم من اي جهه حتى بعد اسبوعين
ونحن ننطلق الى الاسبوع الثالث صحيح هنالك
عدم حسم كامل للمعارك ولكنه لك طرف يشعر
بالنفسه هو متقدم ويسيطر على الميدان بحجم
كبير نتحدث عن الطرف القوات المسلحه هي
الان تتقدم في الميادين وتتقدم في في
التامين
كل المناطق العاصمه الحرب تدور الان بشكل
رئيسي في العاصمه التي تؤكد هذا الكلام
لانه على الجانب الاخر الدعم السريع ايضا
يقول بانه سيطر على الخرطوم بينما يقول
الجيش بانه سيطر على
90% من العاصمه الا اماكن قليله الدعم
السريع لم يقصد تستطيع حتى الان انه يسيطر
على مغاره واحد من مغاره كل مغرات الدعم
السريعه الان ضربت وشتت والان الدعم
السريع هو فقط مغرضته في الازقه والشوارع
وتحت الاشجار ولذلك هذه قوات الان مشتته
في كافه انحاء العاصمه لا سيطر لحد عليها
كل المواطنين الان يعانون من قوات الدعم
السريعه التي تدخل منازله وتنهب البنوك
وتنهب
الشركات وهي تحولت الى عصابات متناثره
داخل الاحياء وداخل الطرقات الامر كذلك
لماذا لم يعلن الجيش بشكل واضح وحاسم بانه
حسم المعركه
من الجيش حسن المعركه بشكل كامل لا زالت
هنالك جيوب لا زالت هنالك فراغ من من
الدعم السريع
تتجول هنا هنا بين الاحياء في الطرقات
تمارس الارهاب على الناس داخل منازلهم في
الطرقات وهذه فيديوهات منتشره في كل
السوشي الان اليوم
المفوضيه الحقوق الانسان بجنيف اصدرت بيان
واشارت فيه لان الدعم السريع يحتل بيوت
الناس ويعتدي على المؤسسات ويحتدي على
المستشفيات هذا
قال الجيش في بيانه ان تامر كان كثيرا
مخططت له في الداخل والخارج اذا كان داخل
معلوما من المقصود بالخارج وهنالك اشارات
انا لا اعلم بالضبط ماذا يقصد الجيش لكنه
هنالك اشارات لطائرات قدمت من الخارج وتم
التعامل معها هنالك حديث عن
بعض القوات تدخل من غرب افريقيا هنالك
حديث عن يعني وجود بعض الاسلحه
الاماراتيه هنالك اشارات لكن لا اعرف على
وجه التحديد الى ماذا الجيش شكرا لك سيد
عادل الباز الكاتب والمحلل الاساسي
السوداني كنت معنا هنا في الاستوديو
تسابق عده اطراف الزمن في محاوله للتواصل
الى وقف دائم لاطلاق النار في السودان
ولاقناع الطرفين المتحاربين ببدء مفاوضات
وفي خضم هذا النشاط الدبلوماسي المكثف قال
رئيس بعثه الامم المتحده للدعم في السودان
فولكر ان الطرفين بات اكثر انفتاحا على
المفاوضات
تقترب الهدنه الخامسه من نهايتها
والمواجهات العسكريه مستمره يكمل الطرفان
اسبوعين من الاقتتال دون ان يلوح في الافق
ما يشير الى ان احدهما قادر على حسم هذه
الحرب لصالحه بسرعه
يحمل كلام مبعوث الاممي الى السودان باصص
امل عندما يقول ان الطرفين المتحاربين بات
اكثر انفتاحا على المفاوضات ويشير الى
انهما رشحا ممثلين لهما للمحادثات
المقترحه في جذب السعوديه او جوبا بجنوب
السودان لكنه يتساءل بشان ما اذا كان
بامكانهم الوصول الى هناك فعليا والجلوس
معا يحيل هذا الكلام الى تصريحات سابقه
للقائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو تحمل رفض كل
منهما التفاوض مع الاخر
فهل تفرد التطورات على الميدان والضغوط
الاقليميه والدوليه على الرجلين الجلوس
الى طاوله المفاوضات
يبدو في كلام المبعوث الاممي بدايه اجابه
على هذا السؤال مع دعوه للضغط على ما يرفض
الحوار وان انتصر في الحرب كل دول المنطقه
ودول العالم يعني لازم ان
لازم ان يقولون يعني بكل القوه انه اذا
استمر هذه
الحاله
فحتى اذا انتصر جهه على جهه ثانيه
فستكون
ستكون جهه مرفوضه دوليا في المشهد
الدبلوماسي تبدو تحركات ثلاثه اطراف هي
الامم المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي
والولايات المتحده الاكثر ديناميكيه في
نيروبي بحث رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي
متفكي مع الرئيس الكيني ويليام روتو
تطورات الازمه السودانيه يشترك الرئيس
الكيني مع رئيس سيد جيبوتي وجنوب السودان
في وساطه منظمه الايجاد التي اعلنت مباشره
بعد اندلاع المواجهات
يحاول المنظمه التي تضم ثمانيه دول منها
السودان حل هذا النزاع الذي تعرفه ان
شظاياه ستصل كل دولها اذا طال امده في ظل
هذه الاجواء يقول مصدر دبلوماسي للجزيره
ان الاتحاد الافريقي يجري اتصالات مع
الامم المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي لتقديم
خريطه طريق لانهاء الازمه في السودان
واشنطن تظهر بدورها نشاطا متزايدا منذ
ذراع الازمه فيما يبدو انها عوده امريكيه
للاهتمام بالشان الافريقي كان ذلك واضحا
في دورها في تحقيق الهدنه الحاليه وان لم
تحترم كليا وتبقى جهود دول الاقليم
العربيه منها بالخصوص لاغناع الطرفين
بالحوار غير معروفه الجهود الدبلوماسيه
ليست كلها علنيه بالضروره والمامور الان
اقناع البرهان وحميتي الا احد منهما سيربح
شيئا من هذه الحرب وانا الخاسر الاكبر هو
السودان
قال وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان دينغداو ان
بلاده تؤمن بان حل الازمه يبقى بيد
السودانيين وحذر من تدويل الصراع واضاف
وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان في مقابله مع
الجزيره مباشر انه لم يوضع جدول زمني
للقاء بين البرهان واحمدته
الرئيس سلفاكيرا الذي يقود فريق الايكاد
اتحدث الى البرهان وحميتي
وابلغهما بان هناك الحاحا على اهميه
لقائهما في جبه لم نحدد بعد سقفا زمنيه
لذلك لكن الرئيس سيلفاكار اكد لهما ان
المساله ملحه
وعليهما ان يبعث بممثلين عنهما في سياق
حوار سياسي يتطرق لوقف الاقتتال وهذا شيء
جوهري ومهم الدوله جنوب السودان تؤمن بان
حل الازمه يبقى بيد السودانيين ونحذر من
تدويل الصراع
وقال نائب المتحدث باسم الامين العام
للامم المتحده فرحان حق ان ايا من الطرفين
في السودان لا يمكن ان يحقق نصرا عسكريا
وقال ان الامم المتحده تعمل مع شركائها
على محاوله للتوصل الى اتفاق لوقف اطلاق
نار طويل المدى واشار في نشره سابقه مع
الجزيره الى انه لم يتخذ بعد قرار بشان
المفاوضات بين الجانبين
قلنا بشكل واضح بان اي من الجانبين لا
يمكن ان يحقق نصرا عسكريا انه حل خطير
وشاهدنا مدى الضرر الذي لحق بالسودان
وشعبه ما ندعو اليه مع شركائنا في الاتحاد
الافريقي هو محاوله التوصل الى اتفاق لوقف
اطلاق النار وقد ناشدنا الطرفين والمجتمع
المدني للسير على طريق العمليه الانتقاليه
لابد من العوده للمفاوضات السياسيه ووقف
اطلاق نار طويل لتقديم المساعدات
الانسانيه في هذه المرحله لم يتخذ قرار
بشان المفاوضات ما زلنا نعمل على ذلك
في اليوم الخامس عشر من المواجهات بين
قوات الدعم السريع والقوات المسلحه اعلنت
وزاره الصحه السودانيه مقتل اكثر من 500
شخصا في حين وصل عدد المصابين الى نحو
4600 شخص جراء الاشتباكات بين الجانبين من
جهتها قالت نقابه اطباء السودان ان 70% من
المستشفيات المتاخمه لمناطق الاشتباكات
متوقفه عن الخدمه وذكرت النقابه ان خمسه
عشر مستشفى تعرض للقصف كما اخليت 19
مستشفى اخر بشكل قصري وتعرضت ست سيارات
اسعاف للاعتداء واشارت النقابه الى منع
طواقم الطبيه من نقل المرضى وايصال
الامدادات الطبيه
وفي خضم التحذيرات المحليه والدوليه من
انهيار النظام الصحي في السودان لاسيما في
العاصمه الخرطوم يواجه مستشفى النوم في
مدينه ام درمان نقصا حادا في الادويه
والمعدات الطبيه كما يعاني المستشفى من
نقص حاد في الكوادر الطبيه التي تواجه
مشاكل كبيره في الوصول الى مقر عملها مع
استمرار تدفق المرضى وتزداد المعاناه بشكل
كبير في قسم غسل الكلى بسبب توقف
الامدادات وعجز المرضى عن الوصول الى
المستشفى
في حديث للجزيره شدد على ضروره وقف القتال
فورا في السودان كي تبدا الاستجابه
الانسانيه للمحتاجين
بدايه علينا ان نوقف القتال فورا وعندها
نستطيع اطلاق الاستجابه الانسانيه قبل بدء
الازمه كان الثلث سكان السودان بحاجه
للمساعدات ومن الواضح ان هذه النسبه قد
ارتفعت خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين لذلك فان
الامر الملح الان هو ان القتال يجب ان
يتوقف
انضموا الينا من بيروت الدكتور احمد
الدخيره المدير الاقليمي لمنظمه اطباء بلا
حدود اهلا بك دكتور احمد دكتور احمد يعني
دخلنا الاسبوع الثالث من المواجهات مع
تقييمكم للوضع الصحي والبنيه التحتيه
الطبيه في السودان
على حديثك الوضع الصحي في السودان حاليا
هو كارثه هو قابل الانهيار الاعظم نحن على
الشفاء
سقوط كامل المستشفيات بقدراتها العمليه
سواء كان في الخرطوم وهو ما يتم التركيز
عليه في تقديركم ايضا يجب علينا التنبيه
بان العديد من المستشفيات
ان الكارثه الصحيه التي حدثت تحمل الكثير
من المسؤوليه لكل الاطراف المتنازع
هو يجب عليهم الايقاف القتال حمايه
الاطراء المستشفيات العاملين عليها
والسماح لكل
المتحصلين للخدمات الوصول الى تلك المشاكل
طيب اكثر من هدنه تم تسجيلها الى حد اليوم
هل استطعتم الاستفاده من هذه الهدن
كمنظمات صحيه طبيه انسانيه
سيدتي شكرا لك على هذه النقطه
يجب علينا ان نقرر حتى اظن هذه الحدوث هذه
المدن فهي
ايضا يؤدي الى عدم امكانيه وصولها المرضى
او المستحقين لخدمه المستشفى وذلك
بالاضافه الى الطواحمص
صحيه وكما ذكر ان العديد من المستشفى
وايضا انا تم التعرض العديد من السيارات
الاسعاف بالاضافه الى العديد من المستشفى
تم احتلالها ايضا تم استخدام هذا الله من
قبل احد الاطراف المتنازع فهي لا تختم او
لا يمكن
انسانيه ندعو للقاف كل عمل العمق حتى نقوم
بتقديم خدماتنا
طيب الى حد الان ما الذي قدمته منظمه
اطباء بلا حدود داخل السودان وماذا عن
الدول المجاوره للسودان حيث يتم انتقال
العديد من السودانيين من هذه الدول منها
من السودان الى هذه الدول
منظمه
حدود
تستمر في تقديم خدماتها نحن ندعم الرعايه
الصحيه في السودان
بالاضافه الى
ولايه الحضاره
بالاضافه الى ذلك في الدمازين بولايه
الازرق وفي الفاشر بولايه دارفور
تدعم كل المستحقين
باحداث هذه العنصر بالاضافه الى اقسام
التغذيه وقد عانت منظمه من اقتحام وسرقه
مقراتنا
ومستودعاتنا في مدينه نيالا في جنوب فنحن
نقوم بتقديم المساعده متى تم توفير الامن
والامن الموظفينه
للمستحقين للخدمات شكرا لك يا دكتور احمد
الدخيره المدير الاقليمي لمنظمه اطباء بلا
حدود كنت معنا من بيروت
في الاثناء ينتظر المئه من رعايه دول عده
اجنبيه وعربيه منذ ايام في ميناء
بورتسودان لاجلائهم بحرا وبينهما اطفال
ونساء ويقول بعضهم ان السفن التي تقوم
بعمليه الاجلاء عبر ميناء بورتسودان قليله
مما يطيل فترات انتظارهم مراسلنا اسامه
سيد احمد يرصد اوضاع هؤلاء الرعايه
عمليه الاجلاء التي تكون عبر ميناء
بورسودان ومطار سودان الدولي لا تزال
مستمره طبعا هذه صوره لحشود كبيره من عدد
من الجنسيات العربيه
تنتظر عمليه اجلائهم تحت لهيب شمس حارقه
ويعني يجدون مكانا
ويوطنون انفسهم بشكل ماء لحمايه انفسهم من
من يعني لهيب هذه الشمس الحارقه تحت درجه
حراره عاليه بعض الجنسيات هنا تتحدث عن
صعوبه التواصل مع سفاراتهم بشكل رسمي هناك
من يقول ان ان الجوازاتهم قد تم استلامها
من سفاراتهم ولم يتم اجلاؤهم حتى هذه
اللحظه ولا يعني يعرفون ما مصيرهم ربما
ربما هناك اعداد كبيره منهم يتحدث
السوريون بانهم اكثر من
سوري عالقونا في قربه من بورسودان وكذلك
هناك يتحدثون عن صعوبات كبيره في تتعلق
باجلائهم رغم ان السلطات هناك تقول ان
عمليه الاجلاء
مستمراها تقريبا حوالي السبع والثمانيه
ايام وقف اجلاء السوريين تماما تم اجلاء
حوالي 27 شخص الكلام ده اول مبارح مبارح
لم يتم اجلاء اي سوري التعقيدات اللي وصلت
انه طلبوا من الناس تسجل جوازاتها تم
تنظيم حوالي 900 جواز مفترض يمشي اول
امبارح لا كمان مشى منهم اي احد ما
التنسيق الناس بتقول انه في عندنا مشاكل
في مشاكل في التنسيق بين الجاليتين لكن
لحد الان ما بعرف شو الظروف وكله ما في اي
احد بيعطينا اي جواب معين احنا من هون من
ناشد جميع السفارات العربيه جميع المنظمات
والامم المتحده والدول الاوروبيه ان ينظر
وضعنا الوضع الجالي سريع هون الوضع كارثي
جدا هذه هي واحده من الصور ربما تكون فيها
كثير من الصعوبات التي تواجه الذين يراد
اجلالؤهم في هذه اللحظات هناك ايضا اسر
سودانيه تنتظر عمليه اجلائهم بشكل كبير
هناك اساتذه اساتذه الجامعات هناك اطباء
ينتظرون عمليه الاجلاء
وصل الى دوله تشاد المجاوره للسودان اكثر
من عشره الاف شخص معظمه من النساء
والاطفال كثير منهم غادروا من ولايه غرب
دارفور باتجاه مدينه شرقيه شاد بسبب
الاشتباكات مراسلنا فضل عبد الرزاق رصد
الاوضاع اوضاع هؤلاء اللاجئين من منطقه
كفر التابعه لمدينه ادرس
يستمر اللاجئون السودانيون في الوصول الى
جات والاقامه في مثل هذه
الاماكن بهذه الصوره وهم يرون ان الاقامه
هنا رغم عدم وجود اي امكانيات
اساسيه للمعيشه هنا افضل من
مناطقهم التي غادروها وهي في ولايه غرب
دارفور المتاخمه
لهنا في داخل الاراضي التشاديه هؤلاء هم
قادمون جدد الى هذه
المنطقه
وبهذه الطريقه ينقلون ما تمكنوا من نقله
ومن ثم
فيختارون في اغلب الاحيان تحت
شجره ما من هذه المنطقه
الاقامه فيها
برنامج الغذاء
العالمي بعد تسجيل اللاجئين كفتره اوليه
بدا توزيع المواد الغذائيه
للاجئين واغلبهم كما هو مشاهد نساء واطفال
ويستمر هذا البرنامج توسيع توزيع المواد
الغذائيه
للاجئين الى ان يتم
المخزون الذي توفر حتى الان لبرنامج
الغذاء العالمي وبحسب ما يقولون ما يقول
المسؤولون في برنامج الغذاء العالمي فانهم
يتوفر لديهم الان
كمخزون للطوارئ ما يكفي لمواد غذائيه
اوليه
لنحو 20000 شخص
فضل عبد الرزاق الجزيره
كفر موقع اللاجئين السودانيين في كات
في جديده تطورات الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا قالت المخابرات الاوكرانيه ان
انفجار مستودعا للوقود في مدينه
سيفاستوبول الواقعه بجزيره القرم هو عقاب
طويل الامد ردا على استهداف مدينه عمان
الاوكرانيه وكان محافظ المدينه قد رجحها
ان اشتعال النيران في الخزان جاء في اعقاب
هجوم بطائره مسيره وتتزامن هذه التطورات
مع احتدام المعارك على اكثر من جبهه
لاسيما على محور باخموت شرقا حيث يقول
الجيش الاوكراني انه ماض في صدرها هجمات
الروسيه
اطول معاركي هذه الحرب
هذا خط الدفاع الاوكراني الاخير عن ضخمه
وهنا يتحصل الجند في شبكه من الخنادق في
احياء المدينه الغربيه
سامس يقول الجني انهم يجعلون في خنادقهم
من الجثث سواتر لهم من النيران الروسيه
والروس ماضون في تحقيق مكاسب في مزيد من
اجزاء المدينه المدمره لا يقرون دائما
بانها مكلفه تقول القوات الاوكرانيه انها
لا تفتح تصد عمليات هجوميه روسيه على
مناطق عده في ضخموت كما تؤكد استمرار
القتال في مواجهه القوات الروسيه ايضا
باتجاه
ومارينكا وليما شرقي البلاد
الى غربي لمن تقع عمان على الضفه الغربيه
من نهر
المدينه تعرضت الجمعه لهجوم روسي واسع
النطاق بالصواريخ والمسيرات استهدف
مقاطعات في وسط البلاد وجنوبها لم يكد
يمضي يوم على الواقعه حتى هز انفجار هناك
جنوبا خزان وقود بمنطقه خليج الكوزاق في
مدينه سيفا ستوبل المدينه هي الميناء
الرئيسي لاسطول البحر الاسود الروسي في
شبه جزيره القرم تقول المخابرات
الاوكرانيه الى الهجوم جاء عقابا طويل
الامد ردا على استهداف الروس مدينه اومان
الاوكرانيه
نصحت سكان شبه جزيره القرم التي ضمتها
موسكو قبل سنوات بالابتعاد عن المنشات
العسكريه الروسيه
وتحرير القرن كما يقول الاوكرانيون سيكون
في قلب الهجوم المضاد الذي يتوعدون به منذ
فتره يبدو انها مساله وقت فحتى مالك شركه
فاجنر العسكريه الخاصه يعتقد ان الجيش
الاوكراني مستعد لتنفيذ ذلك الهجوم على
القوات الروسيه قبل الخامس عشر من شهر
مايو المقبل بالنسبه
فان الاحوال الجويه وربما بعض المشكلات
الداخليه هي ما شكلت حتى الان عائقا امام
اقدام القوات الاوكرانيه على تلك الخطوه
في الجانب الاوكراني يرهل الرئيس فولو دي
مرزلينسكي نجاح بلاده في هجومها المضاد
المنتظر بمدى استمرار حصولها على الاسلحه
الغربيه
تكثفت اخيرا وتيره تصليح النوعي لكيف مع
تزايد التزام حلفائها الغربيين بوعودهم
صارت مثلا انظمه الامريكيه للدفاع الجوي
الصاروخي فعاله منذ فتره في اوكرانيا
قد تكون عامله ارباك المحتملا للخطط
الروسيه وغطاء لاي عمل هجومي مضاد ذاك
الذي تقوله وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان
دونه الان مساله الطقس وقرار القاده
وفي مدينه عمان افادت السلطات الاوكرانيه
بارتفاع عدد القتلى المدنيين الى 24 نتيجه
القصف الروسي الذي اصاب مبنى سكنيا في قلب
المدينه وطال ايضا عاصمه كييف ومقاطعات
جنوبيه المزيد من التفاصيل مع مراسل
الجزيره تامر الصمادي
اتواجد الان في احد المناطق السكنيه في
وسط اوكرانيا هذه المدينه التي تعرضت لقصف
صاروخي الروسي فجر هذا اليوم وفقا للسلطات
الاوكرانيه هذا البناء كما تشاهدون تعرض
لاضرار بالغه نتيجه القصف هنالك قتلى
وجرحى في صفوف المدنيين وفقا للسلطات
المحليه هنا مرت ساعات طويله السلطات وفرق
الدفاع المدني كما علمنا ما زالت داخل
البناء تعمل على انتشال مزيد من الجثه
وتبحث بين الانقاض عن ناجين في صفوف
المدنيين وهذا القصف في الحقيقه هو جزء من
قصف واسع كبير تعرضت له عمان الحديث عن
عشرات المباني ايضا تعرضت للقصف والحديث
ايضا عن احراق العديد من او احتراق العديد
من المركبات الخاصه بالسكان المحليين في
هذا المكان وفي الحقيقه هذا القصف تزامنا
وترافق اخر تعرضت له العاصمه
استهدفت هناك البنيه التحتيه لاسيما قطاع
الكهرباء والماء في عدد من المناطق
والحديث عن قتلى وجرحى في مقاطعات جنوبيه
لا سيما في
الشرق ايضا كل ذلك دفع الرئيس الاوكراني
الى القول بان من يتورط في قتل الشعب
الاوكراني لن يفلت من العقاب وان القوات
الاوكرانيه ستواصل القتال حتى اخراج كامل
القوات الروسيه من الاراضي الاوكرانيه
تامر الجزيره اومان وسط اوكرانيا
انضموا الينا من موسكو
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي كما ينضم
الينا من اكياف كبير الباحثين في المعهد
الاوكراني للدراسات الاستراتيجيه الدكتور
ايفان ابدا معك سيد بابل سيد بافل
المخابرات الاوكرانيه تقول ان استهداف
المستودع للوقود في سابع ستوبل هو عقاب
طويل الامد كيف قرات روسيا الرساله
لم يحصل اي رد فعل رسمي واضح عن حصول
اعتداء وطبعا حريق كبير وتم احتوائه الان
ولا خسائر في الارواح اذن هذا
هذا
الامور لم ترد عليها روسيا بطريقه رسميه
بعد هذا الاعتداء ولكن طبعا هذا مجرد
البدايه اذا ان الطرفين الان
على وشك الانغماس في تصعيد كبير في
المواجهات ضمن هذا القتال بين روسيا
واوكرانيا
حيث
[موسيقى]
مساء الخير من كيف
اود ان احياكم او احيي الضيف الكريم
الموسكو والمشاهدين نعم طبعا نحن نستعد
للجزء الثاني او التالي من هذا من هذه
الحرب فهذه الهجمه المضاده او الهجمه نحن
كما نسميها حسب منظور كول طرف اذا
بحسب
تصريحات
شمال الاطلسي تلقت اوكرانيا
من الاسلحه التي تعهد بها الشركاء والان
بدانا نفكر بالتخطيط اما بالنسبه الى شبه
جزيره القرم اوكرانيا تقول انها اراضي
اوكرانيه احتلتها بروسيا في 2014 وبالتالي
من المحتمل ان تكون جزيره القرم احد اهداف
او وجهت هذا
هذا الهجمات ولكن لا يمكن ان نحسم الموضوع
حاليا لاننا موجودون الان على اراد بعيده
جدا عن القرب اذا العمليه اعتقد سوف تبدا
في زاكا او في منطقه
لوكانت
هذان هما او هتان هما الوجهتان المحتملان
ولكن هل الغرب مبدئيا يدعم اوكرانيا في
مسعها لاستعاده جزيره القرم
ان شركائنا قد قالوا
جزيره القرم جزء من الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وقالوا ذلك حتى قبل الربع والعشرين من
فبراير ودمنا هذا السياق بالتالي
تصير استعاده القرم جزءا من استعاده
الاراضي الاوكرانيه على حدود العام 91 حين
حصلنا على استقلالنا ودمنا هذا السياق
ايضا انا اكيد من ان شركائنا لن يكونوا ضد
محاولاتنا لاستعاده القرب ان بعض الشركاء
مثل تركيا مثلا
قالوا انهم دائما يدعمون سلامه الاراضي
الاوكرانيه بما فيه شبه الجزيره
في جزيره القرم وتركيا تشدد على ان القرم
جزء من اوكرانيا ولهذا شددت على هذا
الموضوع وبالتالي
اعتقد ان كافه شركاء الاخرين من الولايات
المتحده والمملكه المتحده ايضا
يدعمون تحركاتنا لاستعاده القرم في الرياض
وفي الفترات السابقه حين كانت اوكرانيا
عذرا على المقاطعه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لم تكن متحمسه فيما يتعلق
بجزيره القرم باستعاده جزيره القرمم
باختصار لو سمحت
نسمع انهم لا يدعمون ولكن الكثير من
الاشياء تغيرت خلا هذه الحرب والقرب منها
سيبدا بافيل اذا
الحرب مقدمه او البلدان يقدمان على تصعيد
في المواجهات بينهما كيف تستعد روسيا لما
تقول اوكرانيا بانه بانها بانه هجوم مضاد
ان القوات الاوكرانيه تحضر
لهجوم وقد اعلن عن ذلك تقول القوات
الروسيه انها مستعده للتصدي لها و
لايقافها لقد جمعت روسيا قوات
بحجم جيد بكثافه جيده لاسيما على خطوط
المواجهه بالاضافه الى اسلحه اضافيه
واعداد اضافيه من الجنود بما يجعلها
مستعده للتصدي لاي توغل اوكراني
هل سينجح ذلك هذا امر متروك
للوقائع بالنسبه الى الاسلحه التي وفرتها
ادوال الغربيه الى اوكرانيا هناك ايضا
احتمال بان يكون هناك اعتداءات
طويله
الامد بالنسبه الى او قد تصلوا من
اوكرانيا الى موسكو قد يكون هناك اذن هذه
الصواريخ قد تكون موجهه الى الداخل الروسي
والامر سيعمل الى روسيا التي
التي هي اصلا تقوم بهذه الاعتداءات على
اوكرانيا او في داخل الاوكراني اذا سوف
نرى هذه هذا نوع من المواجهات في الحمله
الصيفيه التي ربما سوف تحسم النتيجه
النهائيه لهذه الحرب شكرا لك
الخبير العسكريه والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من
موسكو والشكر موصول لكبير الباحثين في
المعهد الاوكراني للدراسات الاستراتيجيه
ايفان اوس
[موسيقى]
اخبر العالم الاخرى والبدايه من العاصمه
الايرانيه فقد بحث الرئيس الايراني
ابراهيم رئيس مع نظيره العراقي عبد اللطيف
رشيد في طهران العلاقات بين البلدين وذكرت
وكاله الانباء الايرانيه ان الجانبين
تناولا خلال المباحثات الملفات ذات
الاهتمام المشترك بين البلدين فضلا عن
مناقشه كيفيه تسديد العراق الديون
والمستحقات المترتبه عليه لايرانه في ملف
تصدير الطاقه حسب الوكاله ومن المقرر
يلتقي الرئيس العراقي خلال زيارته للطيران
ايضا عددا من المسؤولين الايرانيين
وفي مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع نظيره العراقي
قال الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي ان
بلاده ترفض الوجود الاجنبي والوجود
الامريكي في المنطقه وتؤمنوا بان الحوار
الاقليمي سيؤدي الى تعزيز الامن في
المنطقه وحل مشاكلها واضاف ان اي محاولات
لزعزعه الامن في العراق يعتبر تهديدا
لزعزعه الامن في ايران وفق تعبيره
نعتقد ان الحوار بين دول المنطقه يعتبر
امرا مفيدا ويساعد على حل المشاكل وبنفس
مستوى نرفض الوجود الاجنبيه والامريكي
ونعتقد بان الوجود الامريكيه في المنطقه
يزعزع الامن فيها ويضر استقرارها في
علاقات مع ايران ننظر الى المصالح
المشتركه لكن واشنطن لا تفكر بمصالح
الشعبين الايراني والعراقي فلتبحث عن
تامين مصالحها اي محاوله ولو كانت بسيطه
لزعزعه الامن في العراق تعتبر زعزعه للامن
في ايران
نتقدم لكم بالتهنئه لما شاهدت علاقات بين
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه من تطور والتحسن عاملين ان تساهم
هذه الخطوه على تثبيت الامن والاستقرار
والتعاون في منطقتنا في منطقتنا
بشكل يخدم شعبنا وبلدنا والشعوب المنطقه
كافه
قال المرشد الايراني علي خميني ان
الولايات المتحده ليست دوله صديقه للعراق
وان الامريكيين ليسوا اصدقاء مع احد وغير
مخلصين حتى مع الاوروبيين واضفاخ من خلال
لقاء جمعه بالرئيس العراقي عبد اللطيف
رشيد في طهران ان تطور العراق واستقلاله
مهم جدا بالنسبه لايران مؤكدا ان تعزيز
التعاون الثنائي وتطبيق الاتفاقيات
الموقعه يصب في صالح البلدين
قال قائد القوات البحريه في الحرس الثوري
الايراني العميد علي رضا تنكسيري قال ان
ايران تعتزم انشاء بنى تحتيه سكنيه في
الجزر المتنازع عليها مع الامارات وخلق
فرص عمل فيها واعداد هذه الجزر لتكون جزرا
مسكونه بناء على اعاز من المرشد الايراني
علي خمن عين واضاف تكسير ان وجود الكيان
الصهيوني وامريكا في المنطقه الخليجيه
يعرض الاستقرار والامن فيها للخطر وافقه
تعبيره واكد ان وجود السفن التابعه لدول
اجنبيه في المياه الخليجيه لاسيما التي
تعمل بالوقود النووي يعرض النظام البيئي
للخطر
قال وزير الخارجات الايرانيه حسين امير
عبد الله هيان انه اتفق مع نظيره السعودي
فيصل بن فرحان على العمل في الايام
المقبله على اعاده افتتاح السفارات
والقنصليه في البلدين
كاظم خلال الاتصال الهاتفي الاخير يوم عيد
الفطر مع نظير السعودي اتفقنا على العمل
في الايام المقبله لاعاده افتتاح السفارات
والقنصليات الايرانيه والسعوديه في طهران
والرياض زميله وزير الخارجيه السعودي رحب
بدعوته لزياره طهران وانا رحبت بدعوته
لزياره الرياض
افادت وكاله الانباء السوريه الرسميه سانا
باصابه ثلاثه مدنيين في هجوما اسرائيليا
على نقاط بمحيط مدينه حمص واضفت الوكاله
ان الدفاعات السوريه تتصدت لصواريخ
اسرائيليه في سماء المدينه واسقطت عددا
منها
قال وزير الخارجات التركي مولود شاووش
اوغلو ان وزراء خارجيه ايران وروسيا
وسوريا وتركيا قد يعقدون اجتماعا الشهر
المقبل في روسيا واضافت شاووش اوغلو ان
الاجتماع المرتقبه سيكون في اطار جهود
اعاده العلاقات التركيه السوريه
لعقد اجتماع خلال الايام العشره الاولى من
شهر مايو القادم ووجدنا ان هذه التواريخ
تناسبنا ويبدو انها تناسب ايضا وزير
الخارجيه السوري فيصل المقداد لحضور
الاجتماع لكن مكان الاجتماعي لم يتحدد بعد
بشكل نهائي الروس يتفاوضون ايضا مع
الايرانيين قلنا انه يمكننا الحضور في تلك
المواعيد وبعد التفاوض مع الدولتين
الاخرين سيعلمنا الروس بالجدول الزمني
النهائي
قال المبعوثه الامريكي الخاصه الى ليبيا
ريتشارد نورل
الاوضاع والوضع الامني الاقليمي يعطي
اهميه اكثر من اي وقت مضى للدبلوماسيه
والتنميه والدفاع لدعم ليبيا في تشكيل جيش
موحد بقياده مدنيه يكون قادرا على حمايه
السياده ليبيا واستقرارها ووفق السفاره
الامريكيه في ليبيا فان المبعوثه
الامريكيه الى ليبيا ادلى بهذا التصريح
عقب لقائه في شتوت جارد قائد قوات
الافريكام ونائب القائد المسؤول عن
التواصل المدني العسكري
نظمت جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه المعارضه في
تونس وقفه تضامنيه مع من وصفتهم
بالمعتقلين السياسيين وعائلاتهم وطالبت
جبهه الخلاص السلطات التونسيه باطلاق سراح
المعتقلين وايقاف المحاكمات التي وصفتها
بالسياسيه ورفع المشاركون في الوقفه
لافتات تدعو لاسقاط ما وصفوه بالانقلاب
والانتهاكات ضد المعارضين السياسيين
واستهدافهم امنيا وقضائيا حسب تعبيرهم
[تصفيق]
انتقدت كوريا الشماليه بشده اعلان واشنطن
المبرم اخيرا بين كوريا الجنوبيه
والولايات المتحده لتعزيز الرد على النووي
وقالت كيميو جونغ شقيقه الزعيم الكوريه
الشمالي كيم جونغ اون ان الاعلان سيسهم في
تعريض السلام والامن في شمال شرقي اسيا
والعالم لخطر اكبر واكدت ان بلادها مقتنعه
بضروره ان تحسن بشكل اكبر او تحسن بشكل
اكبر برنامجها للردع النووي الخاص
وسيعزز الاعلان تعاون الولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه بشكل كبير في الشان
الدفاعي بما في ذلك النبوي
عمل لا يمكن الترحيب به باي حال من
الاحوال ذلك كان تعليق كوريا الشماليه
الاول على اعلان واشنطن المبرم بين
الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه حول
الردع النووي
كيميو جون شقيقه الزعيم الكوري الشمالي
كيم جونغ اون الشديده النفوذ في
السقف بشده بالاتفاق وقالت انه سيعرض
السلامه والامن في المنطقه وكل العالم
لخطر اكبر وان بلادها ستدافع عن نفسها بما
يتناسب مع نشر اي اسلحه نوويه قرب شبه
الجزيره الكوريه وكان رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه
ينصر قد وقع اخيرا في واشنطن مع نظيره
الامريكي جو بايدن اعلان واشنطن الذي يعزز
تعاون البلدين الدفاعي بما في ذلك الردع
النووي وسترسله واشنطن بمقتضى الاع لان
غواصه نوويه الى مياه كوريا الجنوبيه لاول
مره منذ ثمانينيات القرن الماضي بينما
قطعت سول على نفسها وعدا بان لا تسعى
لامتلاك اسلحه نوويه
الاعلان الكوري الجنوبي الامريكي اثار
ردود فعل واسعه موسكو وصفته بانه سيزعزع
استقرار المنطقه والعالم وحذرت من احتمال
انطلاق سباق للتسلح نتيجه لذلك وقالت
اليابان ان رئيس الوزراء فوميو كشيدا
سيزور كوريا الجنوبيه لتعزيز التعاون بشان
كوريا الشماليه قبل قمه مجموعه السبع
المزمع عقدها في هيروشيما في التاسع عشر
من ماي القادم ظلت برامج الاسلحه الكوريه
الشماليه التقليديه والنوويه بما فيها
الصواريخ الباليستيه التي يمكن ان تصل الى
مدن امريكيه تثير تساؤلات حول ما اذا كانت
امريكا ستستخدم بالفعل اسلحتها النوويه
للدفاع عن كوريا الجنوبيه وحول مغزى
معارضه واشنطن امتلاك سهل اسلحه نوويه وهل
ستتخلى كوريا الجنوبيه عن توازنات دبلوم
ومصالحها الاقليميه لصالح الاهداف
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه اما بالنسبه
لكوريا الشماليه فانها تجدد الرفع شعار
استراتيجيتها الدفاعيه وتقول ان العمل على
تعزيز وضعها كقوه نوويه امر لا رجعه فيه
ولا تفاوض حوله وتتوعد الحليفين واشنطن
وسول برد حازم وساحق وسريع في حال
الاعتداء عليها